this week fresh hell for france
wildfires burning out of control as heat
waves bake land already parched by
drought
[Music]
extreme conditions especially dangerous
for the elderly and vulnerable
we have a few stuff here at this care
home manager rafael's on a crisis
footing so as you can see we have the
water
fans and air conditioning for for the
resident
here the emergency room is stocked and
ready
in 2003
a heat wave killed thousands of old
people across the country yes it is a
dangerous situation as you know many
years ago in france many people died
that's why we have now an emergency plan
as you can see in order to prevent the
risk
at a nearby rescue center they're also
caring for the vulnerable
more than 300 baby swifts almost baked
alive by the heat
when it's 35 outside under the roofs in
the nest it's like
45 or 50 degrees and just suffocate in
another cage sparrows found stuck to
tarmac
melted by the blistering temperatures
and here hedgehogs orphaned by the
drought
some of a rising number of climate
change casualties
we see more animals but it's good shape
at the animals which is very concerning
because every years two animals are
skinnier and skinnier weaker and weaker
so climate change is a death sentence
for some of these animals yes
meanwhile in the fields of the french
riviera the flowers used for the
country's world famous perfumes are also
under stress from the intense conditions
high temperatures are stunting their
growth a lack of water killing off some
of next year's crop
this heat crisis is now touching the
lives of almost everybody in france
whether it's the wildfires burning homes
and communities now or the drought which
will continue to affect businesses long
into the future
for now the french are trying to rebuild
to save what they can in this brutal
summer
siobhan robins sky news south of france